(wooshing)
(booming)
- [Evan] Jonathan has asked this question
like 18 times in the chat,
he really needs an
answer to this question.
Jonathan I appreciate the hustle.
This question if for you.
How does one select
people for a diverse team
which you can trust and grow with?
- [Steven] Hey, Jonathan.
It's a great question and
I think that is something
there's no easy answers
to as an entrepreneur,
because I've made many
decisions, and some bad decisions
over the time and I'm sure we all have.
But I think this, the
smart way to answer that is
obviously, you know, number
one is look for the differences
you need to be successful.
Be quite conscious of that in
and unpick any sort of
deep bias in your mind.
Then pick the individual
and the key thing is,
with all these things,
is have to be aligned around the mission.
You have to be aligned around the purpose.
You know, if you want to
go into the music business
and the individual doesn't like music,
you're going to struggle.
THey've got to bring something,
but the most important thing
is you've got the alignment
and the power of the purpose,
the sense of purpose, the
sense of passion cuz, you know,
being an entrepreneur is hard
work and they're going to have
to work really hard to be successful.
If they don't have that
fire in their belly
that you've got about your big idea,
then, you know, you might as well
shut the conversation down straight away.
Then once they've got that, I think then
you got to ask yourself,
"What is the complimentary skill set?"
"What's the competence?"
"What's the experience that
they bring to your success?"
And that's very dependent on
where you are on your journey.
If it's the idea stage,
it's probably blue skies
because it's probably over a partner.
If it's further down in your
sort of business journey
then it could be around sales,
marketing, social media,
it could be a very good,
I'll say optimization,
it could be, you know, what
is it you need at that stage?
I think you should be very
thoughtful about that.
And then the next thing is
kind of making that decision
and going on with it and
then, you know, honestly,
the best advice to give you
is, if you make a mistake,
make the mistake and
learn early, you know,
just as we do in terms of ideas.
We have a culture where we want
to encourage our colleagues
to fail fast and actually,
again, at Spotify,
just a daily point, they have
sort of an ideas factory,
they expect nine out of 10 ideas to fail.
But one idea will be a kind of
absolute, kind of barnstorm,
a ripper, and they'll be hugely successful
with that one idea.
But I think within the culture
of a great company, again,
you want to encourage people to fail.
There's no fear in failure.
Ultimately if it doesn't
work out as an individual
down the road then it's really
important to just sit down
and be transparent or authentic
and just say, you know,
"it's just kind of not working
out with you, you know,
"I've made a bad hiring
decision, you know, I apologize
"for that, but we just got
to be honest with ourselves."
Yeah, and the great
entrepreneurs I think are always
sort of focused on their business,
almost to a level of
ruthlessness, but they're always
very compassionate with
the people around them
and very authentic about that.
- I agree with everything Steven's saying.
The thought that I'm
going through in my head
just to add to it, is
I like testing people
on different projects.
I think if you can find
an easy way to get tested,
so give then an assignment,
so whether you're bringing on interns or
whether you're in the hiring process,
I'm not a big fan of the
typical job interview process,
I'd rather just let them
get to work on something
and see how it goes.
So I'll give them five
hours to work on a project
and see what comes up and be willing
to be surprised and open to the ideas.
If you have some kind of
way to test people out
on a small, short term basis,
and again, to Steven's point,
if you're aligned on the
mission, here's our goals,
here's where we're trying to get to,
but I'm open to how the path,
how we're going to get there,
if you can find ways to work
with people and test 'em out,
see what ideas might come out,
I think you'll be surprised.
A lot of the people who are on my team,
I have a team of misfits, like
they would have a hard time
getting a job other places,
they had the worst resumes,
their cover letter wasn't great,
but I just gave them a
chance and they surprised me.
Cuz often the skills, if
you're hiring a video editor,
their cover letter doesn't
really make a big difference,
I'm not hiring them for
their writing abilities,
I want to know they can make great videos.
To Steven's point about not
falling into stereotypes
and just giving people a test,
I think you'll be surprised
if you do that with enough people.
(wooshing)
(booming)